foreign
we've got Mir in Chicago Illinois what's
going on Mir
hey guys how are you guys doing doing
good how are you
good I'm doing good thank you for having
me
how can we help today
yeah so
um about seven years ago I filed
bankruptcy chapter seven
because I had a lot of credit card debt
totally about like 50 000 just in my
name my wife had another like 3 000 I
paid that off but seven years ago I just
it was just bad decisions on my credit
card and I just filed bankruptcy because
I I thought I had no other option and
that ended last year
so we were finally able to buy a house
maybe we just bought a house about two
months ago
and my credit card debt is back up it's
just bad decisions again so my wife
because since I already filed bankruptcy
I was only able like I wasn't able to
get approved for a lot of credit cards
but I right now I have about 16 000 in
my credit card debt
and my wife has about 22 000. oh my
goodness and yeah and we're just in like
a really bad position right now
um I'm I think I'm gonna get laid off
from my job and I think in December
because that's what the company is like
that's what they're sounding like
they're gonna lay everybody off in
December they're just shutting down what
kind of company is it
it's a it's a cult so I love it's a
hearing aid company I just work in the
warehouse in the factory so you know
this layoff is coming have you started
looking for other jobs
uh not yet but I am going to start like
this month or next month but
so we just yeah so like I was saying we
bought a house and that is about 220
000. okay we have mortgage left 220 000.
what's the mortgage what do you pay
every month
about around 1 900 so two thousand
dollars almost okay
cars do you have car payments or
anything like that
you know all of all of my cars are paid
off I paid those off as fast as I can
okay no student loans nothing like that
no nothing okay hey what's going on with
these credit cards why why are you back
down the same road that led to
bankruptcy what's going on there
yes bad decisions is like being a
furniture for the house just everything
on credit cards because we don't have
cash
what are you earning household income
combined you and your wife
uh my life doesn't work but so last year
we got a proof our house because I was
making around fifty thousand dollars a
year fifty right since the company yeah
fifty thousand dollars last year but
since like the company is like shutting
down and like they're slowly removing
lots of employees this year on
projectors can make around 35 000. okay
but you're also getting another job
We're Not Gonna if you're we're not
waiting around until December to see
what yeah and your income's already
starting to go down why isn't your wife
working
she's just she's old she used to work as
a nurse but what do you mean she's old
how old is she
55. that's old she's not old
she's not old and she's broke y'all are
broke she's gonna be working till she's
75 at this point if you don't change
something hold on question does she does
she have money are you guys combining
your finances
no she doesn't make any money it's just
um do you guys have anything in Savings
Credit Card yeah
is there anything in savings
no all right I'm um
I um
am holding back a little bit of resp of
frustration with you here your wife's
gotta work that's number one number two
you've gotta get Moo you gotta get
moving my guy there you're heading down
you're literally looking at the map from
your bankruptcy and you're taking that
same path now and you this is your
wake-up call to get off of it you guys
gotta get on a budget you've got fifty
thousand dollars of income your wife's
gonna go out she's gonna get a job I
don't care what it is she's getting
something in the next couple of weeks
and that is going to lead to the next
something that's what she really wants
to do but no matter what she's got to
get income coming in you've got to get
your income up with this next job and
you guys have got to get a clue turn
into the adults that you are and stop
buying things you can't afford it's that
simple you guys are out here just
spending and spending and buying
furniture and going to dinner and trying
to keep up a lifestyle that's not yours
dude and at what cost it's not worth it
who cares how nice of a couch you have
you're feeling this pain of debt you've
already walked through bankruptcy is it
worth it
it's not worth it mayor you called today
because I feel like you're on the brink
of ready to change but you're not quite
there yet and so if you really want to
change you've got to have anger towards
your situation and right now you're just
kind of like I might get laid off my
wife's not worried she's just too old
and we'll figure it out but man I really
don't like having this debt you're going
to be headed toward another bankruptcy
soon if nothing changes You're Gonna
Lose the house if not you're not going
to have a house to put a couch in
because they're going to take away that
house in foreclosure when you lose your
job or you're making 35 Grand and can't
pay your two thousand dollar a month
mortgage
so it's time to cut up the cards are you
ready
yeah you're like a recovering alcoholic
who has the fridge stocked with alcohol
and then you're wondering why you can't
make traction
we've got to remove the Temptation and
ability to spend more than we make yeah
is your wife how does your wife feel
about this is she like hey it's time to
change have you guys had this
conversation or is this you kind of you
know poking around online and finding
the Ramsay show tell me more about that
you know so my son actually told me
about the Ramsay show I thought I might
just give it a call see what advice I
can get yeah she's very frustrated with
me too because
she she doesn't earn any money it's just
her credit card that I'm spending all
the expenses on and she doesn't want her
credit report to go bad who cares about
the freaking credit report yeah you guys
are y'all are focused on the wrong way
beyond that my man correct your credit
score your credit cards all that talk
all that mentality is out the window
from now on we buy things in cash right
we buy things that we can afford A1 step
one today is you guys getting on a
budget that's that's Numero Uno you can
start that tonight that's a good thing
about a budget George you don't have to
it's not something that's in the future
do that tonight A2 is we're starting to
look for jobs for both of you like we're
getting that train going we're not
waiting around is there a reason that
your wife is not worth working aside
from the fact that you guys are elderly
AIDS
no she used to work as a nurse and she
got like really arthritis in her knees
she can't she can't walk that much she
can't stand is she on disability
no she can get a desk job I mean we sit
all day I sit too much
could she work in a hospital setting
sitting down in a different position
can she do teledoc nursing
there's look there's options we can
split hairs about what she there are
options out there what I'm concerned is
I think you guys are cutting yourselves
out I think you're counting yourselves
out and you're so busy trying to use
credit cards that you're not giving
yourself credit that you actually have
the ability to go out there you guys are
smart you can earn money you guys have
the ability to control your finances you
do not need credit cards to do the
things that you want to do on an
everyday basis it turns out George you
can actually buy a couch in cash you
know what I'm saying so I think for you
guys this is just digging deep and
getting to the root of why you're why
it's the why because something tells me
right now I can tell you about budgets
all day I can tell you about the debt
snowball all day but until you get to
the root of why you are the way that you
are the famous words of Michael Scott
why are you the way you are you're gonna
keep doing this this is going to be an
endless cycle and so for you I really
want you to dig deep on this sit down
with your wife really have that come to
Jesus moment of like look we gotta
change we got to do something different
or else we're gonna file bankruptcy
again please don't do this and mayor
we're going to help you out on top of
giving you one year of every dollar I'm
gonna give to you guys one year
Financial Peace University watch all
nine lessons do the budget do all the
steps we teach in that before you go
make another dumb decision and cut up
the cards today it's done and you got to
get on board otherwise you guys are
gonna be right back where you were seven
years ago and I'm more Angry than you
are at this point that's a problem